Battled Republican
Congressman George
Santos, who has lied about nearly
every single thing on his resume.
He is now
speaking out
after announcing
he will temporarily
not serve on committees.
He just gave an interview
to the MAGA friendly network. Okay.
And take a look
And I've learned my lesson.
And you can guarantee
I can guarantee you
that from now on, anything and everything
is always going to be aboveboard.
It's largely always been aboveboard.
I'm just going to go
the extra step now to double
check, cross-reference everything
Let's discuss
with CNN anchor
and correspondent Abby Phillip,
along with Washington bureau
chief for The Boston Globe
and CNN political analyst
Jackie Kucinich.
I'm sorry, I'm
laughing, Abby,
but we're all like no businesses here.
Well, I'm just like,
though, it's
just a matter
I'm going to double
check everything Dude, you lied about
your being a hall of your grandparents,
being Holocaust survivors.
You lied about your name,
you've lied about your businesses.
This isn't like
about like,
oh, I accidentally misspoke
about what year I graduated.
It's well,
but I guess that's the era we're in.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't I don't even
I don't even know what more
there is to say about all of this.
I mean, I was notable to me
that he had a piece of paper in his lap,
maybe notes on what he should say
about telling the truth.
Because at this point,
it's really hard
to know
what he has said about himself,
what he has represented about himself.
That is actually the truth.
And this interview was, as you noted,
with a conservative outlet,
didn't
cover the vast
majority of issues
related to Jorge Santos.
But it's telling to me
that he felt like he had to do it.
He's trying to rehabilitate his image,
but it just simply
does not undo the straight up lies
that he's been telling for so long.
Although we should note,
Jackie, that he does seem to be like
kind of leaning
into this idea
where, you know, he's
just another mag
a victim of the biased media
and the deep split
state and blah, blah, blah.
But like that that's not he.
I never even heard of this guy. Nope.
Nobody's out to get him.
Like,
it turned out,
he has lied about nearly
every single thing about him.
I mean, I would like to know
what member of the media
told him to lie about his mother
dying in nine 11
when she wasn't
even in the country,
according to various reports.
But listen,
he is trying to move past this.
He said in a statement today
he was trying
not to be a distraction for the House
Republican Party.
I think that probably is
not going to come true
given the outstanding investigations
that are currently
working through the process.
As Elise Stefanik said,
didn't mention the investigations,
of course,
but you know, some of these
yes, all the lies
that we've we've talked about are,
you know, they are what they are.
But I think some of his
dubious record
reporting when it comes to his FEC
reports are really going
to turn out
to be truly the most problematic
in terms of
what kind of illegal situations
he might be in going forward.
I think it was Leslie Jones who said,
do you know how much you have to lie
to be known as the lying congressman?
But but in any case, it wasn't just
late night
hosts and comedians
having making hay out of it.
Democrats obviously are.
Take a listen to the chair of the House
Democratic Caucus, Pete Aguilar.
I'm just struck
by the chaos, confusion,
dysfunction of the Republican conference.
They defended
putting him on committees
and now they're announcing that he's
not going to serve on a committee.
So I just don't
I don't understand what
the play of the day is.
I mean, to be
honest, it's a
pretty reasonable question.
Abbi, what is the play here
for Republicans?
Well, as it relates to Jorge Santos
and these committees,
I think that Republican leadership
in particular,
Speaker McCarthy,
realized that
it was kind of a problem
to allow him to be on committees
given that he's fabricated
virtually everything
that he's said publicly about his life
while also trying to kick off
other Democrats from committees.
It just does not work,
especially considering,
as Jackie pointed out,
there are real, legitimate
and very serious questions
about the finances behind
both his personal
you know, representations
on these financial documents
that were submitted
to the government,
but also
about how he funded his own campaign.
Those are serious issues.
And I think there's an awareness here
that it could totally blow up
in the faces of Republican leadership
if they just give it a pass for now.
And the simplest solution
would be for him
to make himself less of a problem,
at least for now,
although I don't really think
that it's going to end up in McCarthy
or anyone else
in the House of Representatives
kicking him out of that body.
I think they need that
seat a little too much.
And Jackie, House
leadership, Republican House
leadership is pushing hard
to oust Democratic Congresswoman
Ilhan Omar of Minnesota
from the House Foreign Affairs Committee.
But some Republicans, including MAGA
firebrand Matt Gaetz, are expressing
concern about such a move.
Take a look
I view the Schiff and Swalwell matter
somewhat differently than I view
the Ilhan Omar matter.
The reason I think a lot of Republicans
want to kick Ilhan Omar off
of the Foreign Affairs
Committee is because
they don't like what she has to say.
It's one thing
to do dangerous things to the country
with intelligence.
It's quite another to say,
I don't like your viewpoint,
and thus I want to remove you
Now, to be clear,
the reasons
that they're giving the House
Republicans for kicking Ilhan Omar
from the committee
have to do with
anti-Israel things
that she said that employed
anti-Semitic tropes,
at least one of which she apologized for.
It's not the criticism of Israel.
There are plenty of members of Congress
who are critical of Israel.
But but Congressman Gates, tells
CNN he just met with Speaker McCarthy
over this issue
and he's pleased
with the compromise resolution
that would allow her to appeal this
to the House Ethics Committee
if he wants to see the final language.
How do you think this is going
to play out?
You know, the thing
that strikes me about this,
Jake and Abby,
is the amount of political capital
that House leadership
is expending on this.
After all, the political capital
they expended on getting
getting McCarthy speakership
at all,
we're not even to the point
where they're actually
trying to legislate.
And this just shows
how much power
each of those members of Congress
have on the Republican side
and to extract
whatever they want from Kevin McCarthy.
And when and when things
are actually on the line,
when things are actually, you know,
affect how the country does its business.
This is
this does not bode
well for Kevin McCarthy, given, you know,
just how much
how much effort they've had to put
put in
these things that are,
frankly, party loyalty votes.
And Abby.
Congresswoman
Ilhan Omar is defending herself
amid this push to oust her.
But she
she made some rather
baffling comments
to Dana Bash on state of the Union
when talking about a tweet she sent
when she said
support for Israel
was all about the Benjamins in 2019.
Take a look
So when you apologized
for that all about the Benjamins
comment you said antisemitism is real.
And I'm grateful for Jewish
allies and colleagues
who are educating me
on the painful
history of anti-Semitic tropes.
What did you learn a lot.
I wasn't aware
of the fact
that there are
tropes about Jews and money.
That has been very enlightening.
A part of of this journey
I don't want to read too much
into Adam Schiff's face there, but
but I think there are probably
a lot of House Democrats
who find it difficult
to believe
that you'd never heard that there were
anti-Semitic tropes about Jews and money.
Do you think in some ways, Abby,
Congresswoman Omar
might actually be hurting her cause here?
Yeah, I mean, definitely.
Congressman Schiff's face
kind of spoke volumes there,
but but yeah,
no, it's
not helpful to say
that you'd never heard
of a pretty well-known trope
about Jewish people
and so at this point,
I mean,
I think that it's not necessarily
helpful for a Congresswoman
Omar to be out there
dealing with this issue in some ways,
as Jackie pointed out,
this is a problem
that Republicans
internally are wrangling about,
and it's not clear that McCarthy even
has the votes to do it.
So, you know, from the Democrats
perspective, it's probably best
to let them fight it out.
But comments like that
certainly don't help.
And but I would say to Matt Gaetz is up
to Matt Gaetz his point,
I think there
there is some legitimate concern
about where exactly the line here is
when it comes
to punishing members
of Congress for things that they say
and that's still being worked out.
Yeah, and I
also think there's
a larger conversation
to be had about apologies and,
you know, allowing people to grow,
whether they're Democrats or Republicans,
are not affiliated at all.
Abby Phillip and Jackie Kucinich,
thanks so much.